[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour est-ce que vous
connaissez à tour la place
àisgi non malheureusement vous n'êtes
pas de tour on dirait non québécois ah
est-ce que vous connaissez la place
àisgi à tour et bien piégé je ne la
connais pas et je suis sûre que c'est
impardonnable est-ce que vous pensez que
la place des femmes dans l'espace public
elle est importante c'est aussi
important que celle des hommes peut-être
même plus tout à fait représentatif de
toutes ces personnes
qui qui ne connaissent pas suffisamment
ces femmes qui ont œuvré pour pour l'art
la littérature la
[Musique]
politique Alice Guy a joué un rôle
essentiel dans l'émergence de la magie
du cinéma première femme réalisatrice au
monde scénariste productrice et
directrice de
studio en 1895 elle assiste avec
émerveillement à la première projection
cinématographique au monde celle du
cinématographe des frères lumièr
[Musique]
elle est aussi l'assistante de Léon
Gomon directeur de la société Le
Comptoir Général de la photographie elle
lui propose alors une idée
révolutionnaire utiliser le cinéma pour
raconter des histoires inventées des
[Musique]
fictions
à seulement 23 ans elle réalise son
premier court-métrage intitulé la fé au
chou première femme réalisatrice de
l'histoire du cinéma elle dirigera plus
de 300 films en France elle fondera même
sa propre société de production aux
États-Unis après avoir fait fortune elle
meurt en
1968 décorée de la Légion d'Honneur alis
gu est une incroyable aventurière
pionnière du cinéma qui verra son
travail injustement méconnu aujourd'hui
femme de marue et la ville de tour lui
rendent
[Musique]
hommage je vais à la rencontre d'Aline
bureau illustratrice dessinatrice qui a
travaillé sur un ouvrage autour de la
vie d'alisg bonjour Aline bonjour Céline
alors vous m'avez donné rendez-vous ici
sur les bords de Loire à tour un endroit
d'exception qui je crois raviv vant vous
pas mal de souvenirs et d'émotions j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps ici puisque je
suis originaire d'Orléan vous pouvez
nous parler en quelques mots de ce
travail que vous avez réalisé autour de
de ces illustrations autour de la vie
d'alisgi il y a quelques années les
éditions Belin m'ont proposé d'illustrer
un ouvrage rédigé par Sandrine beau et
donc on suit vraiment tout son parcours
du début de son métier de sténodactilo
chez gaomon jusqu'à son exil aux
États-Unis la création de son entreprise
Solax jusqu'à son retour en France elle
rentre malheureusement ruinée et oubliée
de tous si vous aviez quelques mots à
souffler aux oreilles de notre jeunesse
vous leur diriez quoi je dirais allez-y
osez et elle aimait beaucoup une phrase
de Roosevelt qui disait il y a pire que
l'échec c'est de ne pas avoir osé
entreprendre donc allez-y les jeunes
c'est votre tour qu'on soit d'ailleurs
fille ou garçon peu importe il faut
aller jusqu'au bout de ses rêves
allons-y osez ayez de l'audace et puis
je reprends la petite phrase d'Alice gu
qui sur les plateaux de tournage disait
binatural soyez vrai et ben voilà tout
naturellement je vous offre des fleurs
des cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même
pas
[Musique]
peur